how many federal crimes do you think
america actually has
fifteen hundred five thousand a hundred
thousand
what if i told you no one actually knows
hooray
yeah but the department of justice
actually tried to count the number of
federal laws and
had to stop because it was just too hard
this means that
there's no textbook that summarizes the
basis for each crime
what the government has to prove in
court or the potential penalty for each
of these crimes
in fact the united states leads the
world a number of people incarcerated
china is four times bigger but it has
only 1.6 million people in prison while
the united states has 2.3 million people
behind bars
we're number one at the founding of this
country the constitution simply
enumerated three federal crimes
piracy counterfeiting and of course
treason but as the decades went by
congress delegated its authority to make
laws to federal agencies who
went to work writing regulations many of
these regulations were passed for good
reasons but those reasons either no
longer exist or
they've simply been lost to time so
let's take some time out to look at
three categories of the weirdest federal
laws that still exist
[Music]
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
so let's begin
our exploration of some of the craziest
laws that still exist in this country
with
the post office the post office is just
about as old as the country itself and
for most of america's existence
few crimes were taken more seriously
than screwing with the mail
the post office's unofficial motto
swells with self-importance neither
snow nor rain nor heat nor gloom of
night stays these couriers from the
swift completion of their appointed
rounds
and in the 1800s you could actually be
hanged for stealing the mail and that's
all well and good to punish people who
misuse the mail
but because we live in a nanny state
where uncle sam is always trying to tell
you what to do
they've trampled on our freedoms to be
able to send people via the mail
unbelievable you might think that no one
would ever do this
but there wasn't actually a law
prohibited people shipping for the first
140 years of the post office
and back in the day lots of people use
the mail service
creatively for example henry brown was
an enslaved man from virginia who worked
with abolitionists in pennsylvania to
mail himself out of slavery
in 1849 brown burned his hand to get out
of work then packed himself in a
shipping crate the journey took 27 hours
and cost 87
about 2500 in today's money he stayed
free and became a well-known speaker
magician and performer and it worked
because back then
it was legal to ship people in fact it
was legal to ship babies and children
between 1913 and 1920. the introduction
of the partial post in 1913 gave parents
exciting new options in child
transportation parcel post allowed
people to ship heavy objects for a
reduced rate
and since parcel post was a lot cheaper
than a train ticket
parents often opted to stick an address
on their kids and send them with the
postman for example a family in batavia
ohio
sent their son to grandma's house less
than one mile away
for just 15 cents but don't worry they
insured him for 50 bucks i mean that's
just good financial planning
and in 1914 an idaho family shipped
their five-year-old daughter to their
grandparents house 73 miles away
she was sent through a train's mail
compartment with 53 cents of stamps
attached to her jacket now sure this
seems like
child abuse but the reason postal
workers were willing to transport
children by mail was actually fairly
touching
families knew their postal carriers well
and trusted them to safely deliver the
children
so i guess kevin costner was right all
along and congress left this slide until
june of 1920 when it passed a law that
made it a federal
crime to male humans regardless of the
weight now that doesn't mean that people
have stopped trying to ship themselves
through the mail
in 2003 a man named charles mckinley
mailed himself from new york to texas in
a box he was convicted of a misdemeanor
stowaway charge in violation of 18 usc
2199 but the heavy hand of tyranny
strikes once again because living human
beings is not the only thing that you
can't send
via the post office no you actually
can't send miniature spoons
why well the usps continues to add to
the list of things you cannot mail which
not surprisingly prohibits sending of
anything by mail that is determined to
be
drug paraphernalia but that includes
things such as miniature spoons with
level capacities of less than one tenth
of a cubic centimeter turns out that
tiny spoons are great for snorting
cocaine yeah so in 1979 congress heard
testimony from anti-drug lobbyists who
talked about the need to get mcdonald's
to stop using their very popular little
coffee stirring spoons these little
spoons were beloved by coffee drinkers
and
drug dealers alike i'm loving it dealers
used to buy them
in bundles and even today these spoons
are sought after you can get them on
ebay but
if they're sent through the mail you
have probably just committed a federal
crime and that takes us to the most
vile of all post office related crimes
and that is that you can't dress up
like a postal carrier yes there are
hundreds of crimes related to the us
postal service
but the worst is of course wearing a
postal carrier uniform which can get you
up to six months in prison under 18 usc
1730. 18 usc 1730 says whoever not being
connected with the letter carrier branch
of the postal service
wears the uniform or badge which may be
prescribed by the postal service to be
worn by the letter carriers
shall be fined under this title or
imprisoned not more than six months or
both eventually congress passed a law
allowing actors to wear usps uniforms
but
only under the condition that the
production portrayed the postal carrier
in a positive light so obviously
like this now if this strikes you as
super hot
but also unconstitutional you're
absolutely right the us once made it
illegal for actors to wear military
uniforms unless the production showed
the military in a positive
manner however the law was struck down
by the supreme court in 1970 since
allowing actors to wear uniforms only if
their role did not discredit the
military
was a violation of the actor's first
amendment right to free speech and even
though that law was struck down it took
congress
21 more years to remove the same
language from the postal worker statute
the law now reads
the provisions of the preceding
paragraph shall not apply to an actor or
actress in a theatrical television or
motion picture production who wears the
uniform or badge of the letter carrier
branch of the postal service while
portraying the member
of that service which of course is how
we got this guy
i'll tell you a little secret about zip
codes they're meaningless
newman but let's talk about the truth
and consequences in food regulation
because often lawyers are literally paid
to engage
in food fights people can be convicted
of many kinds of food crime because the
u.s regulates food cosmetics and drugs
pretty heavily but understanding which
agencies regulate food is
very very complicated even for lawyers
so let's talk about the jurisdictional
battles of the food comps
there are two federal agencies that
regulate food there's the food and drug
administration
and the u.s department of agriculture
the fda is responsible for regulating
labels on all processed foods created
and sold
in the u.s the usda oversees mostly meat
poultry and eggs the fda regulates about
75
of america's food supply and the usda
has the rest and the division between
the two agencies makes for some
delicious jurisdictional battles
take eggs whole eggs shells and all are
the responsibility of the fda but liquid
eggs are regulated by the usda this
might seem strange since an egg is
composed of a shell and some liquid why
divide them but this complicated
division exists throughout the food
regulation regime for example the fda
has jurisdiction over non-domesticated
poultry like wild turkeys ducks and
geese whereas the usda regulates
domesticated poultry like turkey
chickens and yes domestic geese and
ducks but things get even more
complicated when we talk about
sandwiches bread is a bakery product
that is regulated by the fda but
meat like ham or turkey or beef is
regulated by the usda so who regulates a
simple turkey sandwich
well this is where things get really
interesting and by interesting i mean
complicated the fda regulates a sandwich
with
two slices of bread this is because the
fda regulates bread but take away one
slice of bread and make it an open face
sandwich and the usda steps in since the
ratio of meat
to bread and other ingredients is more
than half and this is no laughing matter
the food cops are deadly serious about
it here's a notice from the usda about
inspection of closed-faced sandwiches
that are on their way to canada and the
agency knows that places like white
castle or kfc might shove meat between
two biscuits or pancakes
or even chicken between two slices of
chicken so they have that covered as
well but perhaps the biggest
food-related tragedy in all of law
is that you can't make food with love
that's right companies that get a little
too cheeky with the way that they list
ingredients on their food
could be looking at a prison sentence
check out this mean letter from the fda
to the nashoba
brooks bakery which had the audacity to
include love
as an ingredient in its bread your
neshoba granola and whole wheat bread
wholesale real tale products are
misbranded within the meaning of section
403 of the act
for example your neshoba granola label
lists ingredient love ingredients
required to be declared
on the label or labeling a food must be
listed by their common or usual name
love is not a common or usual name of an
ingredient and is considered to be
intervening material because it is not
part of the common or usual name of the
ingredient that's right neshoba
the government has questions just what
is this love ingredient how much love is
in a pound of granola
is love measured in grams ounces or
pounds what kind of hippie bread and
granola are you cooking up over there in
massachusetts
thankfully for nashoba the fda
encourages self-correction of alleged
violations of the fdca
over criminal prosecution and generally
if a violation is suspected the fda will
provide the alleged offender
with the opportunity to correct unlawful
conduct before taking further action and
to remove
all love from your products however
the government regulators could opt for
prison time if you
demand to add love to your food a first
offense conviction of a mislabeled
consumer product
might carry a maximum sentence of one
year in federal prison or a thousand
dollar fine and the text of the statute
allows the fda to charge both hopefully
the government recognizes that there's a
difference between selling eggs with the
incorrect date for the purpose of
passing off old eggs as fresh
and labeling your granola as containing
lots and lots of love
obviously the love is much much worse
but don't worry
as long as they don't sell and label
them grandma can still bake your cookies
with as much love as she wants
from prison all right we've talked about
the post office we've talked about
eliminating the scourge that is
the love that is pervasive in all of our
foods and let's talk about the final
category of crazy federal laws that is
weather laws and if you've enjoyed this
video so far please give it a like so we
can make sure that more people know
about all the crazy laws that still
exist
in this country but it's also important
that you know not to falsify a weather
report it's actually a violation of
federal law to falsify a national
weather service forecast
and pass it off as official not that any
high-ranking government official
has ever falsified a weather report in
fact if one
were crazy enough to take a sharpie and
falsify a national weather report
you could actually get 90 days in jail
for breaking this law 18 usc
2074 reads whoever knowingly issues or
publishes any counterfeit weather
forecast
or warning of weather conditions falsely
representing such forecast
or warning to have been issued or
published by the weather bureau united
states signal service or other branch of
the government service
shall be fined under this title or in
prison not more than 90 days or both
this might seem like a trivial thing
however if an official violates this law
it's a serious matter the national
oceanographic and atmospheric
administration's national weather
service the nws
is the government agency that provides
weather forecasts and reports across
this country and giving out false
information
can interfere with the farming and
shipping industries and could even cause
people to put themselves
in harm's way and for a practical
application of this law that probably
doesn't get a whole lot of use we need
look no further than former president
trump who caused a controversy by
insisting that hurricane dorian was
tracking towards alabama when it was not
trump made this claim via tweet
what you thought i was going to say that
he made it in a well-rehearsed speech no
he made it in a tweet but the national
hurricane center did not at any point
include alabama in its forecast for
where
dorian would make landfall the nws
birmingham quickly corrected the
president assuring people that they
didn't need to evacuate but
contradicting the president was a big
no-no during the trump era rule number
one was
never contradict the president and of
course an angry president trump
dug in and defended himself by saying
that days earlier the path of the
hurricane included alabama and produced
a chart with a sharpie drawing
the national weather service was under
pressure not to contradict president
trump so
it ended up putting up false information
to cover the president but the law
wasn't actually tailor-made to former
president trump
back when meteorology was still a new
science amateurs were selling weather
forecasts all the time
it's 68 degrees and there's a 30
chance that it's already raining this
was problematic especially when they
asserted that the information was coming
from the us government so the
government's major concern
was that people would hold the
government accountable for bogus reports
therefore they passed laws making it
illegal to falsify a government weather
report but
at an even more fundamental level you
actually can't change the weather itself
without permission for example in 15 usc
330
it actually prohibits anyone from
modifying the weather quote no person
may engage or attempt to engage in any
weather modification activities in the
united states unless he submits to the
secretary of commerce such reports with
respect there too
in such form and containing such
information as a secretary by rule
prescribed section 330 gives the
secretary of commerce the power to
subpoena anyone caught modifying the
weather without proper notification if a
person defies the secretary of commerce
subpoena
the court may find that person in
contempt and jail them and contrary to
popular belief this law was not invented
to fight the my little ponies
rather the genesis of this law is
actually a process called cloud seeding
that was started in the 1940s
it involves sending small aircraft into
the clouds to effectively modify them
and inserting chemicals to enhance
precipitation
dissipate fog modify hurricanes and
decrease lightning and hail in
thunderstorms but cloud seeding is a
pretty controversial act and it's
officially banned in warfare
this is partially because the u.s used
it in vietnam to extend the monsoon
season which
stopped the north vietnamese from moving
troops and materials southward so yes
the weather can be altered but you can
only do it with government permission
and that's not surprising because you
need government permission for a whole
bunch of stuff and we'll go into more
detail about that soon and i explained
one more crazy federal law over at
nebula in fact i posted a whole extended
version of this video over there did you
know that you have to feed your pigs hot
garbage
almost all of my videos have an ad free
extended version on nebula and now you
can get a huge discount because
sometimes talking about hot garbage is
too hot for youtube
which is why my creator friends and i
teamed up to build our own platform
where
creators don't need to worry about
demonetization or the dreaded algorithm
it's called nebula and we're thrilled to
be partnering with curiositystream
because nebula is a place where creators
can do what they do best
create it's a place where we can both
house our content ad free and also
experiment with original content in new
series that probably wouldn't work
on youtube and not only are my nebula
versions add free and extended but
they're also released early before the
youtube version nebula features a lot of
youtube's top
educational-ish creators like extra
credits real engineering and wendover
productions
and we also get to collaborate in ways
that probably wouldn't work on youtube
and put out amazing original content
like half as interesting as courtroom
drama where i play a real life
fake lawyer so what does this have to do
with curiosity stream well as the go-to
source for the best documentaries on the
planet like peter sagel's history
spelled with a dollar
sign they love educational creators and
we worked out a deal where if you sign
up for curiosity stream with the link in
the description
you'll also get a nebulous subscription
for free and to be clear that nebulous
subscription is not a trial it's free
for
as long as you're a curiosity stream
member and right now curiosity stream is
offering 26
off of their annual plans that's less
than 15 a year for both curiosity stream
and nebula so if you click the link in
the description you'll get both
curiosity stream and nebula for 26
off or you can go to curiositystream.com
legal eagle it's a great way to support
this channel and
educational content directly for under
15
a year that's less than the cost of
legal eagles patreon so just click on
the link in the description to get
curiosity stream and nebula together
plus
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel now leave your objections
in the comments and check out this
playlist over here with all of my other
videos about
crazy laws and legal misunderstandings
so click on this playlist
or i'll see you in court